on this tuesday night vaccine mandates
put on pause
what unvaccinated canadians will soon be
able to do it's probably been overdue
what's changing what stays the same and
why you'll still need to pack your
patients flood fears and flashbacks in
southern alberta i think that this
brings up a lot of memories of 2013.
what makes this year different
cryptocurrency crumbles the consequences
as investors fear bitcoin is bottoming
out
and the whiskey war is over
the friendly feud between two allies
over one tiny island
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with changes coming to cobit 19
vaccine mandates in this country as of
june 20th people will no longer need to
show proof of vaccination to travel by
plane and train within canada and to fly
to destinations outside canada though
they'll still have to adhere to the
rules of the country they're going to
the majority of canadians more than 80
percent are vaccinated and the federal
government says the rules were never
meant to be permanent
we don't regret it all
being cautious when it comes to a virus
that has tragically killed
tens of thousands of canadians
and millions of people around the world
masks will continue to be mandatory on
planes and trains and this is not a
complete relaxation of vaccine mandates
the arrive can app for example will
still be enforced for canadians
returning from abroad and foreign
nationals coming to canada will still be
required to show proof of vaccination
abigail beeman has our top story on the
rule changes and the questions
surrounding the timing of today's
announcement
good news for millions of unvaccinated
canadians soon able to get on a plane or
train while civil servants on unpaid
leave will be called back to their jobs
the suspension of the vaccine mandate
was informed by key indicators including
the epidemiological situation and
modeling
vaccine science and high levels of
vaccination against covet 19 in canada
pressure to drop mandates has been
mounting with international attention on
airport chaos you're starting to see a
populist
resentment of these policies and that
must have influenced government policy
to some degree though with arrive can
still in place the government says this
wasn't motivated by travel delays nor
will it help i think that
in essence it's probably a bit overdue
my own opinion is that it's not
because we do see rates going up
elsewhere especially like for example in
the united states with new variants many
aren't satisfied by the lack of specific
benchmarks both for removing mandates
now and potentially bringing them back
they sort of close one door and open up
another with this announcement
it is a temporary suspension sam
pres-velos is a lawyer who launched a
constitutional challenge against federal
vaccine mandates still in court
what what happened in june
that did not exist in may
for the government to make this decision
and what does the government need to see
in the fall or in the winter
to change its decision people are always
looking for a magic date and a magic
number and if kovid has taught us one
thing there is no magic date where
everything's suddenly resolved while the
health minister says they'll focus on
boosting canada's low booster rate with
two-dose effectiveness waning we have to
look at the horizon and what may change
this decision in the future is an
updated vaccine and for now mask
requirements are sticking around on
planes and trains abigail beeman global
news ottawa
news of vaccination requirements being
suspended is being hailed as positive
news by the tourism industry some
travelers feel the change is long
overdue others feel like it's a bit too
soon dan spector has been taking the
temperature of travelers
at trudeau airport in montreal some
travelers say they're ready to pile onto
packed planes again regardless of their
neighbor's vaccination status it's about
time i think personally others worry not
necessarily for themselves but for those
traveling without increased protection i
think we're fine i think the
unvaccinated people are the guys you
have to worry
on this via rail platform some
trepidation
i think it's premature yes proof of
vaccination for air and rail travel has
been mandatory since october but as
montreal revs up for one of the biggest
events on the summer calendar the
formula one canadian grand prix the news
of relaxed domestic travel requirements
represent a bit of relief for the
beleaguered tourism industry another
step in the right direction that's for
sure
the industry isn't altogether happy it
still wants inbound international
travelers to be exempt from vaccine
rules over 50 countries have moved
forward in terms of
international
allowing international travel so i think
would like to see canada do the same
cruises still require anyone on a ship
get a covet shot too they were closed
down for two solid years we didn't have
cruise ships coming into port and it's a
real challenge
for them the hope is that unvaccinated
public sector employees being allowed
back to work could help relieve staff
shortages contributing to long lines at
airports even still canadians are being
asked to pack their patients as more
people traveling might further expose
worker shortages in hotels restaurants
and other attractions a recommendation
is travelers you know should be patient
and and should be nice to the people who
are serving them the tourism industry
hopes the mandate suspension is made
permanent so businesses and travelers
can confidently plan for the future and
replace unknowns with certainties dan
specter global news montreal
the alberta government is going a step
further dropping all its remaining
public health restrictions at midnight
masks will no longer be mandatory in
public transit and even if people have
symptoms and test positive for covid19
isolation will no longer be mandatory
masks will still be required in high
risk settings such as hospitals in a
statement today the province points to
falling hospitalizations and infection
rates as justification for the move
heavy rain and strong winds are creating
challenges in calgary tonight which is
under a state of emergency the heavy
rain is prompting flood concerns across
the region a high mountain snowpack is
also cause for concern recent government
surveys show snow levels are more than
double the usual amount in some places
four southern alberta river basins could
see water surge if temperatures rise
suddenly for now the cooler weather is
prevailing that's helping keep river
levels at bay but memories of the flood
in 2013 are still fresh for many
calgarians heather urex west is in
calgary where people are watching the
weather closely
donna it is a sickening sense of deja vu
for so many who live near the bow river
there was already a lot of snow in the
mountains causing river levels to rise
during this spring melt but with up to
150 millimeters of rain expected to dump
on this region the risk of flooding now
is very real
in the pouring rain calgary crews have
been busy moving dirt to construct a
protective berm in the hopes of keeping
the nearby community safe and dry i
think the tensions are and anxieties are
running high and i think that this
brings up a lot of memories of 2013
and just all of the trauma associated
with that for residents this is a far
too familiar scene conjuring memories of
a similarly rainy day nine years ago
when the bow elbow and highwood rivers
burst their banks flooding more than 14
thousand homes
one of those homes belonged to jamie lee
and owen tipton but nearly a decade
later the high river couple says they're
not afraid this time around i kind of
feel at peace with what the town has put
into
with the town with the mitigation so
i i don't i don't have any fear
i have calm
a lot of things are different in
southern alberta now and while not all
flood mitigation projects have been
completed residents are confident in the
changes made and the storm itself is not
like it was then either every weather
event is different i think this one is
serious and it's an issue but it's not
nearly as impactful as that event back
in
2013. like 2013 this rain comes from a
slow moving system that has parked
itself over southern alberta but unlike
2013 up until now this spring has been
relatively dry the complicating factor
is we have an above average snowpack in
a lot of the higher elevations and so
once the rain starts to fall in those
areas it intensifies and actually gives
us a bit of a worse problem as that snow
melt increases the water flow but it's
not just the rain wreaking havoc strong
winds tuesday downed trees and power
lines interrupting service to more than
8 000 homes now the good news is that
it's colder today than it was in 2013
meaning the precipitation up in the
mountains isn't rain it's snow which
means less water is likely to find its
way down here donna right heather
urich's west in calgary tonight that
snow will eventually melt though the
question is how fast and how much rain
will fall in the meantime global news
meteorologist tiffany lisa is watching
this for us tonight tiffany
donna this system has been quite intense
it moved into parts of b.c as well as
alberta throughout the day yesterday and
it continues to bring heavy rain
thunderstorms and even some funnel
clouds to parts of the prairies
throughout today the good news is that
moisture in the rockies is falling as
snow reason that's good news is because
that will result in a slower melt which
allows those river systems to catch up
whereas if it was heavy rain onto
snowpack that's a quick melt and then we
could see a higher risk of severe
flooding this system is going to slowly
push its way east bringing some heavy
rainfall into parts of northern
saskatchewan wrapping its way
counterclockwise not only heavy rain but
strong winds is what we're dealing with
with this system as well throughout the
day today here in calgary wind gusts
nearing 90 kilometers per hour that's
starting to uproot trees right in front
of our station we have a tree uprooted
because that soil is so saturated right
now so we'll be watching this system
over the next couple of days as it does
push east it will start to disorganize
and then we'll shift our focus on rising
river water levels and how it will
impact the bow river as well as the
elbow river so that's the situation as
we move into wednesday as well as
thursday donna
all right global news meteorologist
tiffany lisa and calgary thanks the same
storm system caused flash flooding in
yellowstone national park in wyoming and
montana
oh my gosh
the power of the water was frightening
washing out roads and carrying away
buildings all entrances to the park have
been closed indefinitely and visitors
taken to safety the yellowstone river
rose more than two meters from sunday to
monday reaching the highest water level
since record keeping began in 1918 and a
winter storm warning is now in effect
for higher elevations
zero justice for 72 victims five years
later coming up the grim anniversary of
the grenfell tower inferno in london
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
made another appeal to world leaders
today he spoke with prime minister
justin trudeau and says they coordinated
next steps in counteracting russia's
aggression zielenski is pleading to the
west for more heavy weapons calling the
human cost of the battle for eastern
ukraine simply terrifying
ukraine
says he needs more modern artillery to
ensure ukraine's advantage russian
troops now control about 80 percent of
the fiercely contested city of sevier
donetsk and have destroyed all three
bridges leading out ukraine's defense
minister says up to 100 ukrainian troops
are being killed and 500 injured every
day russian forces are edging closer to
total control of ukraine's eastern
donbass region
there's concern for alexei navalny
tonight the russian opposition leader
who has been poisoned and imprisoned his
close associates say he's missing from
the prison where he was serving time
russian state media reports he's been
transferred to a high security penal
colony but his lawyers say they were not
informed of the move navalny has been a
vocal critic of president vladimir putin
he's serving nine years on what his
supporters say are politically motivated
charges since navalny was arrested in
january 2021 the kremlin has cracked
down on his supporters and independent
journalists in an attempt to stifle all
dissent
canada's foreign affairs minister faced
more questions today about why a senior
diplomatic official attended a function
at the russian embassy last friday the
deputy chief of protocol went to a
russia day event despite canada's
condemnation of russia's war in ukraine
the foreign affairs minister says her
office did approve the appearance but
she personally did not know about it
until later
i didn't know and that's why i'm
frustrated of course but of course
i'm the i'm the minister
so of course i
the box stops here
the big question right now is how can
canada support ukraine as they're trying
to
accede to the eu
so of course we will support them
in london it was five years ago today
the world watched an apartment building
housing low-income people become an
inferno all 24 floors of grenfell tower
were engulfed in less than 30 minutes
and no one has been held responsible for
the litany of failures that led to it 72
people died
today the bereaved and survivors along
with the duke and duchess of cambridge
gathered for a memorial service many
wearing green that's become a symbol of
the tragedy it's believed an electrical
fault in a fridge caused the blaze in
the social housing block but it was
flammable cladding that lit up like a
torch spreading so fast residents
couldn't escape a public inquiry is
ongoing but five years later no criminal
charges have been laid and families are
still waiting for justice and
accountability
after a day of fast-moving developments
it now appears a controversial flight to
deport asylum seekers from the uk to
rwanda won't carry anyone somewhere
between three and ten people had been
expected to be on the first flight to
the rwandan capitol this evening that
flight has been cancelled because of
last minute legal appeals the european
court of human rights issued an 11th
hour injunction and 30 other migrants
facing deportation won their high court
appeals on health or human rights
grounds prime minister boris johnson
says the policy is designed to interrupt
the business of human traffickers and to
discourage migrants from traveling to
the uk in small boats
cryptocurrency crash ahead the digital
market meltdown and who is left in the
lurch
you're watching global national
[Music]
a month after the federal government
banned 5g technology from chinese
companies huawei and zte new legislation
is being proposed that would require
canadian businesses to report cyber
attacks
as we incorporate and integrate new
technologies into our economy we also
have to be very sober about the national
security landscape as it exists
the bill would make it mandatory for
telecommunications finance energy and
transportation companies to share
information as the federal government
tries to get the full picture of
increasing attacks it's impossible to
ignore the carnage going on in the
cryptocurrency market as inflation soars
many investors are panicking abandoning
their appetite for risk bitcoin has
plunged about 70 percent in value from
its all-time high crypto exchanges are
shutting down and jobs are being slashed
and gaviola looks at what's behind the
market meltdown
fortune favors the break
matt damon's multi-million dollar
crypto.com super bowl ad is now drawing
comparisons to this from pets.com the
ill-fated internet company that paid big
bucks for this spot before the tech
bubble burst in the early 2000s back to
the present where the ongoing crypto
crash has wiped out tens of billions of
dollars of investors money the market
downturn raising questions about how
long some crypto companies that have
responded by freezing withdrawals have
left before they go under crypto is
being treated like high growth tech
stocks which are also selling off risk
assets like
crypto or you know small caps or all the
specs or the memes everything that sort
of has
risk on it difficult to value
it's the stuff that's going to get sold
off because investors are scared on
monday the s p 500 entered a bear market
coming down at least 20 percent from
recent highs investors are worried about
persistent inflation rising interest
rates war in ukraine kova disruptions in
china the list goes on and on now this
isn't the first time bitcoin has seen a
massive crash it took big tumbles in
2018 2021 and has been falling most of
this year cold comfort for investors who
sold during the plunge it's really
affecting a lot of people that invested
and
i feel sorry for them the cryptocurrency
in this space right now it's it's so
fresh it's so new
there's a lot of great projects going on
coinbase one of the biggest crypto
trading platforms now says it's laying
off 18 percent of its workforce citing
rapidly changing economic conditions and
an admission that the publicly traded
company grew too quickly there's going
to be a much greater role
and a much greater need in many respects
for for thoughtful regulations and
policies around around this asset class
prompting renewed calls to regulate an
industry that remains the wild west of
investing
anne gaviola global news toronto
who won the whiskey war next canada's
decades-long battle with denmark over a
tiny arctic island
a bid led by four vancouver area first
nations to host the 2030 winter olympics
is moving ahead the concept was unveiled
today it includes reusing many of the
venues built for the 2010 olympics and
moving some ski and snowboard events to
sun peaks resort a four and a half hour
drive from vancouver it's the first ever
indigenous led olympic bid led by the
lillowitz musqueam squamish and swala
tooth nations a detailed breakdown on
the projected cost to host the games as
promised for next month
canadian and danish officials can raise
a glass now that a decades-long land
dispute is settled it's okay if you've
never heard of it the island is tiny but
it's been at the center of the so-called
whiskey wars where expeditions from the
two countries have been using bottles of
booze to stake their claims
now as michael a reports officials are
agreeing to share the island and a brand
new border
hans island is not much to look at okay
maybe it's ruggedly handsome but beyond
that the 1.3 square kilometer rock has
no intrinsic value beyond being a
traditional inuit hunting ground there
are no minerals to mine no oil to drill
yet for 50 years its territorial rights
have been no laughing matter would you
mind if i clipped you on that
the island sits way up north in the
nearest strait exactly 18 kilometers
from canada's ellsmere island and 18
kilometers from danish territory
greenland and therefore within
territorial rights of both countries
the dispute turned ugly in the 1980s
thanks to sadly canadian troops who
planted a flag and left behind a bottle
of whiskey the opening salvo in the
so-called whiskey war prompted a rebuke
from the danes who replaced the whiskey
with some danish liquor and something
called pork shoulder picnic because what
says ownership more than a picnic
but when canada installed a plaque
claiming ownership on the island in 2005
the danes had had enough and they called
the canadian ambassador to complain
ultimately they agreed
to talk
which led to this we're ending
the dispute that for many
that many called the whiskey war at a
news conference in ottawa it became
official a deal was reached to split the
island roughly in half and the
friendliest of all conflicts is now over
canada and denmark signed the deal
sealing it with a handshake an exchange
of bottles and a message to vladimir
putin that diplomacy works yes we have a
border with the eu now but also we're
sending a message to an another neighbor
up north when it comes to arctic
sovereignty canada's foreign minister
had one more thought now that we share a
land border with an eu country
does this mean we can compete in
eurovision micro life global news
toronto
that's something to look forward to that
is global national for this tuesday i'm
donna friesen tonight's here canada is
the inch aaron lighthouse built in 1870
in dalhousie new brunswick we'd love to
see your canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com
and thanks for watching hope to see you
here again tomorrow bye
[Music]
you